in this video we're going to explore
Khan Academy's Mastery goal system
at Khan Academy we're committed to the
concept of Mastery learning which is
embodied in our Mastery goal system
but what does Mastery goal mean
essentially it is a tool that allows
teachers to establish and monitor goals
for their students while also promoting
self-paced learning when we talk about
master goals we're referring to a
student's ability to understand a
subject thoroughly and do so at their
own speed
think of Mastery goals as your students
personal learning map in subjects like
math or even our new digital sat reading
and math courses
course Mastery covers a year worth of
discoveries and learning it's your
students long-term goal
unit Mastery on the other hand is like a
treasure hunt within the big adventure
it's all about finding and mastering
skills for just one unit at a time it's
your students short-term goal
let's walk through how to assign Mastery
goals to your students when you log into
Khan Academy you'll land on the teacher
dashboard
click on the name of the class you want
to create a Mastery goal for
on the left hand side navigation go to
the Mastery goals Tab and click assign
if you haven't done so already add the
on grade level course you currently
teach
click the blue hyperlink edit courses
next you'll be on the course Mastery
placement page
click create course goal
you can confirm you're assigned and
desired goals to students by selecting
Mastery goals on the left hand panel and
then selecting progress
you will now see the current Master
goals assigned to students your class
and their progress towards meeting that
goal
now let's look a little closer at what
students see in terms of Mastery goals
when students log into Khan Academy they
will be on their learner homepage
each student will be able to see their
teacher or class name on the left hand
side
by clicking on the class students will
see their Mastery goals at the top of
their page
a student can click the goal at any time
and continue from where they left off to
make progress towards their goal
students can also continue working
towards their Mastery goal on the IOS
and Android apps as well
there are several ways for students to
practice they can practice a single
concept at a time on an exercise or they
could practice mixed skills on a quiz
unit test course challenge or Mastery
challenge
as students get questions right they
move up from not started to familiar to
proficient
the top level is mastered students can
only get to Mastered by getting to
proficient and then getting that concept
right again in a mixed skills setting
Mastery challenges can be used for
Spiral Review and they're just six
questions each
it will appear for each student when
they have reached familiar level on at
least three skills and have reached
proficiency on at least one skill
the Mastery challenge refreshes every 12
hours we do like to think of this as a
spiral review
most teachers recommend having students
start with a course challenge or a
specific unit test within the course
students May navigate to the course
challenge in their account or teachers
May assign the course challenge
this way both students and teachers can
quickly identify gaps and strengths in
students knowledge in order to provide
the right content and the right support
at the right moment
course challenges contain 30 questions
and can be used as a pre-assessment as
well as a progress monitoring tool
a master goal is considered achieve once
a student reaches 80 percent of their
course Mastery goal
we'll be diving deeper into reports in a
later session but let's take a look at
where to find Mastery progress for
students
starting at the teacher dashboard select
a class
select Mastery goals from the left
navigation menu
then select progress
this report shows student progress on
the assigned course
Khan Academy also has a skills report
found under the activity tab to dive
deeper into the individual skill for a
given course
on the skills report you can open any
unit to get a quick view of how students
are progressing
by clicking on a specific skill you'll
be able to see the Mastery level for
every student for that skill
if you notice that several students are
struggling on his skill you can assign
extra practice on that skill right here
in the skills report
we'll talk more about how to make
assignments in a separate video we hope
this video helps you start using Mastery
goals with your students
foreign
[Music]